where we left off in the last video we
were focused on surface two this blue
kind of outside or i guess the blue side
of our little kind of chopped cylinder
that we're dealing with and we found a
decent parameterization and then given
that parameterization we were able to
come up with ds for that surface for
surface two just simplified all this
business simplified to one so it just
equaled d u dv and so now we are ready
to evaluate the surface integral this
surface integral right over here we're
ready to evaluate
we are ready to evaluate the surface
integral over surface two of z
ds and it's going to be equal to a
double integral over u and v
and so let's write this
i'm going to do two different colors for
the different variables of integration
so yellow for one and maybe purple for
the other purple for the other and we're
taking it we're taking the integral of z
and in our parameterization z is equal
to v so this right over here is the same
thing as v so we can write v right over
there and we already saw that d s is the
same thing as d u dv or we could even
write that as dv
dvdu we could just switch the order
right over there and i'm going to choose
to integrate with respect to dv first to
do dv on the inside integral and then d
do du on the outside integral and the
reason why i'm choosing to integrate
with respect to v first is based on the
bounds of our parameters v is bounded on
the low end by zero it's bounded on the
low end by zero but on the high end it's
bounded by essentially a function of u
it's upper bound changes because you see
right over here depending where we are
depend
depending on what our x value is it
essentially we have a different we have
a different height that we need to get
to and since it's a function of u we can
integrate with respect to v our
boundaries are going to be 0 and 1 minus
cosine of u
1 minus cosine of u this all of this
business and magenta will give us a
function of u
and then we'll be able to integrate with
respect to u and u just goes from 0 to 2
pi and so that will give us a nice
straightforward a nice straightforward
number assuming all of this works out
okay and so this is simplified to a
straight up double integral and now
we're ready to compute and so let me
write the outside part the outside parts
from 0 to 2 pi
it's d u and so the inside part the
antiderivative of v
is v squared over 2 and we are going to
evaluate that from 0 to 1 minus cosine
of u and so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to once again
the outside integral 0 2 pi i'll write d
u i'll write d u right over here
and so we're this is going to be equal
to
all of this let me just write one half
and actually i can even write the one
half out here i'll just write one half
times 1 minus cosine u squared well
that's just going to be
1 squared
minus 2 times the product of both of
these so minus 2
cosine of u actually let me give me let
me give myself a little bit more real
estate here let me give myself a little
bit more real estate 1 minus 2 cosine of
u
plus
plus cosine of u squared cosine of u
squared minus this thing evaluated at
zero which is just going to be zero so
we just get that right over there and
then we have
and then we have d u and so now we can
evaluate this we can integrate this with
respect to u so let's do that
so the answer and i'll just let me just
take the one half on the outside just to
simplify things so we have the one-half
out here and so if you take the
anti-derivative with this of this with
respect to u you still have this
one-half out front so this is equal to
one-half
and we're going to take
the anti-derivative so let's do it
carefully actually let me just simplify
it so it's easier to take the
anti-derivative so it's going to be
one-half times the integral i'll break
this up into three different integrals
one half times
times the integral from 0 to 2 pi
of 1 d u which is just d u
minus
minus 2 times the integral from 0 to 2
pi
of cosine
of u
d u that's this term right over here
plus the integral from 0 to 2 pi
of cosine squared u and cosine squared u
it's not so easy to take the
antiderivative of that so we'll use one
of our trig identities i always forgot
the for forget the formal name i just
think of it as the one that takes us
from cosine squared to cosine of 2u so
this trig identity this thing right over
here is the same thing this comes
straight out of our trigonometry class
this comes this is one half
plus
one half plus
one half cosine of two theta plus one
half cosine of two or i should say theta
cosine of two
u so this last integral right over here
i can rewrite it as i can rewrite it as
i'll just rewrite in that same color
actually one half plus one half
cosine of two u and then we have our
final
we have our final d u and now and then
let me close the brackets and all of
that is times one half so this thing
right over here cosine squared u just a
trig identity takes us to that now this
is pretty easy to evaluate the
anti-derivative of this is just going to
be u evaluated at 2 pi and 0. so it
essentially just let me just write it
out this this part right over here is
just u
evaluated from 0 to 2 pi it's 2 pi minus
it just gets evaluated and we get 2 pi
so out front you have your one half and
then times 2 pi and then this right over
here the antiderivative this is going to
be equal to minus 2 times the
antiderivative of cosine of u well
that's just sine of u
sine of u evaluated from 0
to 2 pi well sine of 2 pi is 0 sine of 0
is 0. so this whole thing is going to
evaluate to 0
so we could say minus 0 and then we take
the anti-derivative of this right over
here the anti-derivative of this is
going to be
anterior of one-half is one-half u
one-half u and the anti-derivative of
one-half cosine of two u
well if we had a two out front here then
that would be that would be the
derivative of sine of two u but we don't
have a two out here but we can add a two
let me actually write it this way we can
add a two right over here
we can add a two and then divide by a
two
we can add it to that that's a little
bit too confusing let me make it very
clear one-half
one-half cosine of two u is equal to
one-half times one-half right let me
write this way is equal to
1 4
times 2
cosine
2u these are the exact same quantities
and the reason why i would wrote it this
way is this is clearly this is the
derivative of sine of 2u so when you
take the antiderivative of this
it's the same thing as
plus
that same color
1 4
sine
of 2 u and we're going to evaluate that
from
0 to 2 pi and you can confirm for
yourself you take the derivative of this
you do the chain rule you get the 2 out
front 2 times 1 4 gives you 1 half and
the derivative of sine of 2u with
respect to 2u is cosine of 2u now we
need to evaluate this at 2 pi and at
zero when you evaluate it at 2 pi you
get one half times 2 pi
which is pi so this is plus pi
plus pi
plus 1 4 times sine of 2 times 2 pi sine
of 4 pi that's just going to be 0. so
this is going to evaluate to 0 and then
minus 1 half times 0
and then 1 4 sine of 2 times 0 this is
all going to be 0 when you put 0 there
so this whole thing evaluated just two
pi and we're in the home stretch at
least for surface two and i'll switch
back to surface two's color now now that
we're near the end so this the integral
uh the surface integral for surface two
is going to be one half times two pi
minus or sorry minus zero plus pi so
it's one half times three pi
which is equal to which is equal to we
can have our drum roll i guess our mini
drum roll since we're not really done
the entire problem right now but it's
equal to three pi over two
three pi over two so we're making pretty
good headway this was zero and now this
part right over here is three pi over
two and in the next video we will try to
tackle surface 3.